what would you say are the three big
flags that a man or a woman should look
out for when they're entering a new
dating relationship uh competition or
cooperation when you have a partner that
values your well-being and wants to see
you feel less anxious wants to see you
feel happy wants you to feel connected
they are Cooperative so when they say
when you say things like oh babe I
haven't heard from you or day they're
like oh I'm so sorry I completely forgot
I'll call you in 5 minutes give me 10
minutes I'll call you but other times
you'll have a partner where you say oh
you know I haven't heard from you stop
trying to control me you're always
taking over you're so needy is stuff
like that is is it competition or is it
cooperation when you voice a concern do
they actually want to see that you the
relationship get better and your
well-being matters or are they so stuck
on their autonomy and Independence and
not being controlled by you that they
reject and neglect their
responsibilities towards you it's those
partners that are in competition with
each other who can hurt food the most or
who can stay the most disconnected who
can stay the most independent why are
you together I don't understand those
relationships it's torture it's real
torture so it's like oh I'm liking extra
pictures if she told me not to like
pictures now I'm going to do 10 times
more oh you know he told me not to post
bikini pictures now I'm going to post 10
times more why are you together if
you're going to hurt each other because
it hurting them should be hurting you